hi everyone
uh welcome to another design review for
in our season of design reviews version
13.
this is supposedly a quick review i
never believe in this quick reviews
theory
about uh control theory and systems
modeling
all right so what have we got here
expanded so it's a relatively
um in some ways small
uh an incremental update so all of our
control design functions
up until now has supported something
called the regulating
controller
that tries to bring something into
balance to a
stationary point
so for instance like maintaining a
pendulum upright
is one of those yes
there is a neighboring or near
problem which is trying to
follow a system that it tracks
that is not necessarily zero for
instance or it changes
that's called the tracking controller
okay so in other words you you're trying
to have a duck bounce up and down in
some
thing or whatever yeah and the goal is
can you keep things bouncing like the
duck was supposed to bounce
yes as opposed to can you keep something
at um
uh
so it has a path so like a plane as
opposed to flying at a fixed altitude
it's supposed to be following some
particular trajectory is that the idea
yes
and we so the typical example see
there
for tracking is like a cruise control
system for a car or path tracking for a
robot
those are
why does i mean cruise control is mostly
a fixed speed
yeah but it's typically not zero
and
it's slightly subtle but actually i
think i can so i'll teach you some
intuition behind controllers here okay
so
if you
let's say that you want to maintain some
speed 70 miles per hour
if you
uh
with a regulating controller you know it
can it needs to somehow integrate the
error in order to drive that difference
from what it achieves to what you would
like to zero yep okay that means it
needs to build
basically this tracking problem that he
wants to mainta get that to zero it's
like an integrator part
and that's that's what the
that's effectively what the tracking
problem does it builds an augmented
system that models the the signal that
you want to track
this is complicated stuff
yes
but it's a more it's a it's a moderate
update
how do how is this tracking introduced
how do you specify it in the in the
design here you specify it
with it's a key value in the first
argument if you go scroll little up you
see that
the detailed system specification
that table
little below below that area and there
is attract outputs
so usually that needs to refer to that
variable we use in the input
yeah where
i was talking about the design yeah
it's just a documentation issue
but the beginning here is basically
trying to describe what those two
problems oh i see this one here is the
detailed thing
yes yes and then this yeah this is not
quite the way we do it but yeah i
understand so these are the elements of
the asoc there
yes
whoops out puss is like an octopus
but it has a t missing there
yes um
i don't understand this i mean what
what's what type of thing do you set
tracked outputs to be yeah we explained
that in the table even below it's either
the index in the case
the next table yeah
it's the numbered output
or in the case of system model objects
it's the name of the variable
okay
i just can't help very much with this i
i don't i don't know enough
we'll get back i mean i'll i think it's
useful to this thing now you stand a
fighting chance to understand these
problems if you read the beginning there
i think that it's a significant upgrade
to get you know to become learning pages
um which should be still enhanced
further as we know exactly
these pages but yeah yes absolutely then
the other side apart from this this
completes the control picture and we
discovered this when we started to do a
bunch of scenarios with what we released
in twelve three
the other side which we also discovered
when we started to do control design
with system modeler as a modeling
language
and because you can't do control design
without a model you always control
indeed
and so was that these layouts if you
look here in the first one
that the the the graph layout
basically inside of system modeler for
these diagrams were pretty horrible
so those are now curated because we know
in these scenarios how they're going to
be
the other enhancement that we also
discovered is that it's rasterized
because our graphics language didn't
include some of the vector graphics
language the system model had like
gradients which it now does
and so now we've switched that over to
use
vector graphics for the icons so they
look crisp and nice
um question question so i mean
this whole framework
this
reinforcement learning
etc these are kind of
the same story in the end although in
very different notations and
formulations is that correct
sort of um so what we're getting to is a
style of doing design which is called
optimal
design optimal control
um
and
what reinforcement learning does is
provide a
good way of approximating those
basically
yeah so yes they are the same but
you know like control deals with
minimizing costs
um
reinforcement learning deals with
maximizing um
um sort of what is it that you maximize
again
um fitness of some kind but i mean yeah
i mean so there's a sort of flip
notations but yes it is this is it's
it's the same picture
it's the same thing and we will get
to that
next up for for for 13.1 is is another
step along the way called model
predictive control
okay but i have a question i mean
the minimum
use of this stuff i mean in other words
does this escape from engineering
systems is there is there a use for this
stuff and no examples here there is but
it's apparently closed
if you look at cell bracket
okay
i'm just trying to understand and think
about where does this intersect with the
rest of the system or is this a is this
a tentacle
or does this intersect with other things
we're doing
it it's sort of so first of all the
system representations
the transfer functions and the state
space models they're also used by signal
processing they use the same
backbone
uh
you know and those you know so so all
these filters that we do for instance
they're transfer functions
um
the
uh it intersects in a variety of ways
and i think we will find more i mean so
one thing look i mean we have a whole nd
solve
you know pde solving capabilities uses
that this uses that when you want to
simulate and see how your system
performs you need nd solve and so i know
that i know that
but i mean for example let's say pdes
yes there's any way of sort of gluing
this into that to have it
it's it's in principle there is it's
very not much developed in either
academically or practically to do
controlled design for for pd's for
distribute what we call distributed
systems
okay
so it's odes and dies that's the killer
you know and delay equations and and so
on
why does that plus not work
well this was a pro i mean i don't know
how
uh so once the system model
functionality loads it works
what do you mean when it loads
but how do i know it doesn't load what
do you mean when it loads how do i load
it
uh when you run any system model
function okay so it's not good enough to
have it just be dead here you understand
what i'm saying
this either has to cause it to load or
send a message or you know produce a
message or some such other thing does
that make sense
can't just be dead
fair right
do i need to invent some ux i mean this
thing could say
i think it should maybe it should pop up
something here that says
um you know load now or whatever else
did you understand what i'm saying right
so if i click that right if i click it
rather than just being dead
which it isn't now
right it should say
the click should produce something here
that says
capabilities is not loaded load now or
something
okay something like that unless you
think of a better way to do it
okay so let's say
why is that grayed out like that
what's it doing why is it gray like that
yeah
uh so we we have a fade in for
when the model is too latch
uh
but that looks
when did not happen
that's always been the case but it
shouldn't fade this side
i don't understand what is this i don't
understand is it a dot dot dot on this
side you understand what i'm asking is
is it like this chain goes on much
longer
uh in this particular case i don't think
so
but so why is this faded what's going on
uh right i think we have to correct the
fading
i think it's a bug i i've never seen
this before
well that looks like it's
faded on the right
because it's not big enough somehow
okay how do i get
how do i how do i get something more out
of this
uh
well so if i take that thing
and i say
as we always do
why is this taking forever to paste it
what is it doing what is this doing what
is it doing it's just a freaking picture
why is it taking forever to paste
do you understand my question
uh right why did that take a long time
to paste
well it's a full graphic object that's
nonsense nonsense nonsense
nonsense
there's something else going on here i
don't know what it is but nothing to do
with graphics takes no time at all to
paste a graphic
it takes time what is going on here
is there something dynamic that remains
dynamic did anybody from the front end
team ever look at this
what is this
does it doing a kernel round trip to
paste it
did you understand my question
probably does
okay you need to look at this this is
wrong
okay something is wrong here
do i need to drill it even harder to
find out what it is because this
right is displaying this
right
how is it doing that
so yeah it's it's a dynamic object that
reaches out to
find the model diagram and displace it
okay was it cached
where is it cached
what is it going to a different process
to do that or what
uh
right yeah is this cache and depending
on the state of the button it's uh it
displays either the minimized or the
expanded version
sorry i didn't get that i didn't
understand that
it's where is it cashed
where is the cash i don't know if it
uses a cash
i don't think it does i think it's just
nonsense
i think it's re computing this every
time and that's why it's taking forever
and that's wrong
also
you know whatever this is doing if if
there's something omitted here it should
first of all this is not the way we omit
things it's a dot dot or some such other
thing second of all it should say how
much it's emitting third of all this
thing shouldn't be just completely dead
if this is such a dynamic thing there
should be a bunch of uh you know some
kind of
thing here that is allows you to ask for
properties of this thing directly and
interactively you see what i'm saying
right
so i why don't we have that i mean given
that it's taking forever
to what does that true mean there
what does true mean in the second
argument of system model
i don't know
i think it means expand it but i don't
know
it's just
seems to not be documented so what's
going on here
what's going on is there some hack of
some kind i think we use it for the
track uh
the state of the model if i'm not
what do you mean by the state
i think this is both a
an input and a representation i
understand that i understand that's fine
okay then
what but i think it
what's that
that's something to go debug who's who's
project managing here
is it addison yep i just wanted to
download
okay look
there's a lot of beautiful stuff here
but for goodness sake it's got to fit in
better and not do crazy things like take
i mean you must have seen that it took
forever to paste things right you have
seen that before right
right
okay so what did you think when you saw
it
you have no idea why it takes so long to
paste or everything will take that long
to paste
it shouldn't take any time to paste it
should take no time at all once it's
already rendered here every asset
associated with it should be cached
do you see what i'm saying okay
there's no reason that it should take
any time at all
so
roger who can they talk to
to get this straightened out
who helped them what's that
um so
multibuilt this but the question is who
who could talk to sort of for setting up
yeah i would imagine that that would be
somebody in the front end team lou or
somebody who designates right
okay
i'm pretty sure this is just set up
wrong that the way this dynamic works is
wrong
yeah
okay i think that there's a round trip
going but it's one can i know even if
there's a round trip i i i know i know
it's on the client's side
okay i know simple stuff
simple stuff and whatever this fade out
i mean this this graphic looks beautiful
i don't know why we faded i've never
seen that before it's something very
strange
okay all right but now why can't i click
on the components here i mean because
it's never we've never allowed clicking
on components okay and what would you do
you would just get the graphics of it
there's no drill down there's no
okay there's no graphics why is there a
dot dot dot here given that you've got a
million miles of space
to stick i don't know maybe it looks
like a bug to me
so let's get it fixed
right i'm guessing there's a fixed
length at which that why
why yes because it can occur small i
understand but that's why we have a
dynamic object here it can trivially
resize itself
right that's the whole point this is a
dynamic object that's taking forever to
to render you can render it at the size
it's at
okay in any case
what kind of thing does the fluid
library so how do i get to that library
how do i get to the flow dynamics
library the documentation for it
uh on our documentation page
which page
reference.wolfram.com system modeler
right i think it is
that's that system model
no system modeler no no that's not the
right thing right because yes it is for
all the library stuff
look look look look let me let me point
something out to you
every other page so this should have a
link right there if there's a sub
well yeah
we can do that
but it needs to point to a whole world
okay so
there's too big a space here alison
that's for you this is incorrectly
formatted there
got it
right i understand but what we do if you
look at for example let's say we go to
import
okay i know what we do but but this is
purely this is a whole separate product
doesn't matter so point to the website
we will okay
fine and there's a whole world
okay but so so if i go there so let's go
so i'm going on the web here
to
reference the orphan dot com slash
system modelo right i think so
is there a dash in it
i don't know
okay there we go
okay so that's the that's the home route
guide page of system modeler okay
so now i want to get to the fluid
libraries
so
not there
um so the question is if they've made it
to this page or not
because they were in the things that we
are shipping today it was experimentally
supported
by the way i mean this could do with a
facelift obviously this is some
generations old
yeah
please but that's the hydraulic library
that you're in now
okay but fine but but what does this how
do i tell what this is
what do we mean
well i just don't i mean it's i'm kind
of lost here
maybe i should look at a liquid
container
let's click to copy which is nice but i
don't understand there's no examples
here
yeah they're linked to examples used in
examples too
okay
this is fuzzy
yeah because
that's the thing that's shipping
right that's not
okay fair enough but that that so if i
take that
what well the hydraulic library was an
extra library right that doesn't come
with it
so then you need to get the library so
then the click to copy shouldn't should
do should say something about that
presumably
um the click to copy is can we can can
the build system modify click to copy
it can put in dependencies yes although
that is a fairly new feature
okay
okay fair point
but then we'll we'll use that feature
then yeah yeah right
so i'm not sure it's built i i need to
bring up my own version so i can check
now okay so um but it's in system
moderate a product you know there's an
experimental support for it
and in 13. why is that blue there that's
another bug
that was just a bug right
okay magnificent
so then what i could do here
given that i have this why is it taking
so long what is it doing okay when it
does that dot dot what is it doing can
you explain please
uh it's fetching all the graphic
primitives and generating the graphic
object okay it shouldn't be taking that
long it's not that complicated graphic
it shouldn't be taking that long
something else is going on
somebody is launching some weird
external kernel or some such other thing
i mean it it is a separate kernel it's
the know
i know but i'm just but it wasn't
launched it was already there that's
what i thought but i'm telling you
there's a bug there's something wrong
because it's not working at a reasonable
speed for what it is
i mean this is magnificent what it's
doing here
not that i understand it but it's
magnificent
um
how is this doing at getting working in
the cloud
so it started to work and we are working
on some workflows and one of the
workflow issues that come up is that you
often need additional files so you need
a notebook project kind of the
discussion we had with video
but it is working with some limitations
but when you do publish publish doesn't
treat the dependencies right wait a
minute but something like this so can i
run this yes yes that that would just
work because there's no dependencies
you're not adding anything else that's
all there so in other words if i go to
the public cloud yes
right now yeah it should work
and i go in there
and i paste that in
and i run it
okay
have you guys
who thinks they're debugging this
okay that was very good that that worked
it would have been really good to have
some kind of progress monitor there
also this is awfully small
well let's see what happens if i press
that
nothing
wait a minute guys who who's actually
looked at this from this team
who's looked at this
i guess that would be
me
[Music]
okay
but so so have you tried it because i
mean this is obviously not very good
so this is what you see in twelve point
three so this is okay so but so that
will work beautifully now right
okay so if i say system model plot
of that thing
okay so where are the messages
that should have come up
so the there is a is currently uh that's
very nice well done guys
sorry please go ahead
right there there's currently a uh
a book that we're fixing the program but
that was very good well done
i'm really happy to see that
when did that start working
the last release which i can't remember
the numbering scheme for the cloud
anymore oh you mean the cloud 159
okay 159
um that doesn't seem easy to remember
but it's not very easy to remember
okay does it ever gonna get to two
uh eventually yes and the definite
triggers for it to go into two i need to
disappear to another live stream in a
few minutes but let me think we're good
here stephen i think i i want to address
a few of the thing questions and
comments that came up on my livestream
all right
i
um
okay
who is looking i like the cleanup of
stuff like this on these speed issues
are you doing that roger or is somebody
else doing we are doing this this came
in so late that we didn't really have a
shot at it before this okay so that's
that's an issue there when things come
in super late we cannot do that
iteration too yeah all right fine but
but now it's time yes
ethan is asking why is there no robust
reinforcement learning here yet
not quite sure what that because it
isn't there
you mean it isn't done yet
yes
um
calais commenting looks like a storm
nobody has looked into for a few years
that's
unfortunately partly true
um
yeah so what we what you're seeing is
this slow i mean it's still we're not
putting a lot of resources into this yet
but we're putting some resources and
what you see
is is a sort of a gradual refreshing
of you know particularly
the control side and
and but also the way system modeler
interacts with the wolfram language well
i'm right and the most important thing
there is making all this into entities
what is the progress why is that
important who cares about that okay
we talked about this for the last five
years roger but i still don't get it
okay cares about that okay the whole
point is we did that and we did that
several years ago no no but i still
don't get no you didn't hear us about it
where is okay where do i
needs to be here okay if we're gonna
have this discussion okay we can't have
it without money okay well when we need
to have that discussion i mean how do i
type in a piece of natural language and
get this
i have no idea so right that's the point
you've got to be able to do that so hey
that's an example
okay a component i don't know i want a a
dash part
right i want to pull up a dashboard how
do i do it
is there a dashboard i am sure there is
a dashboard somewhere as one of the
components in system modeler but not
here
right
uh because those have never been hooked
up we already have system model entities
uh
uh i don't know if there is a dashboard
but we definitely have okay so so there
so if i say entity list
and i say system model yeah that was
done many years ago how can it have been
done it's not in the autocomplete here
well
is that does that mean it's not done
i don't know
but it's not in the autocomplete so some
somewhere some
lines got dropped i mean the fact that
it's taking a while
you're gonna get all the models this is
gonna be a large output because you're
gonna get all the models well that's
fine but why was it not in the
autocomplete for entity list that's a
super bad sign
because that means it's not integrated
into lots and lots of subsystems
sergio can you talk to malte what he did
along those lines and we can crazy
release notes no this is just garbage
somebody just threw everything in here
this is garbage
no no this is just garbage
that's not what's supposed to be done
it's just garbage
come on guys
contact information
come on guys that's not what goes in
this is just somebody doing the thing
that people do it's like when when the
us defense department said
all software should be written in ada
and what do people do they machine
translated from the languages they were
using into ada and produced just garbage
there it's the same kind of thing this
is no good
come on guys let's actually do this
properly so it actually works
so you can actually use it
well we have to kind of start that over
then but sergio can you start by talking
to malta and bring my data to our next
meeting yeah
get a conversation about integration
yeah okay
let's let's let's you know let's look
this over i still don't get the use case
okay you'll get it you'll get it and
you'll realize that once we have this
i never missed entities
um
okay that's because you're not dealing
with real world things i suppose m
all day long
well i don't know i can't comment on
that that's a large part of our system
so you're not using it so i can't
comment on that
once these things are properly
integrated into the system people will
use these
as
pieces of other things they're doing
like nd solve with one of these in the
middle of it or something like that all
kinds of things like that will start to
work
which they don't right now
and there will be quite a ways to make
that work
i understand
i understand
but i mean that that's maybe a more
extreme case even doing it you know
using it with predict and classify and
all that kind of stuff that's easier
not the components why would you yeah
just
i think that's right
yeah no
um
okay
comments from richard here
about pd solving for deeper learning
integrating numerical solver into the
training process
yes yes yes that's a somewhat different
direction is using machine learning for
pdes this is something that we're
working on but that's a different
different story from this yes
ethan was asking will the system model
stuff ever work in the cloud and
it does it does
yes video is not yet working in the
cloud
yes it is
no not in this version
is it yes
all right let's see
ethan had an example here we'll just
paste it and see what happens
that doesn't look like it's working to
me what should we do here video format
is not supported for playback
ah so it has a more limited set of
formats
the the codex that it supports is more
limited should it have a conversion
mechanism
i thought that we had
i think maybe that was then then up for
discussion yes it should have but it's
that was being debated
you know
but i thought that we came that that was
already resolved
well we should resolve it and i mean if
necessary it should either have a button
you press here to do the conversion or
it should just start doing the
conversion if it has to do that for i
agree i agree but it was so hard to get
it to go in the first
anything go in so but
that needs to be there now for a second
round
isis commenting that the reason they
learned what language is because of
entity stuff
good i am i am glad
right
this is garbage roger this is
embarrassing this is that list yes it is
i see that now too okay as i said i you
know whenever i try to use entities it
doesn't know what i want to know
just doesn't [ __ ] know
okay well whatever
um
ah richard is commenting that the the
stuff he's mentioning is about passing
reinforcement learning passing gradients
through the environment etc
yes
um
all right well okay anything else for
this
no
okay um all right thanks very much and
so for those who are following live
streams we are about to do a completely
different live stream about some
research type stuff
so